ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
games both coverage III 2014 I'm Chris
waters taking over for the stage here
happy to join you here on GameSpot calm
or twitch wherever you're watching us
we're glad to have you and I'm super
excited because my two guests right now
the cofounders of sledgehammer games are
here to talk about Call of Duty advanced
warfare
it's Michael Condrey and Glen Schofield
gentlemen welcome to the stage thank you
Chris thank you great to be here excited
to have you guys here especially after
that dynamite trailer you showed during
the Microsoft press conference yesterday
that was the reaction been to that but
phenomenal people been coming up to us
and just saying great job and we've got
a lot of people jazz you know absolutely
and I can speak for GameSpot folks we
were all in our HQ watching it and like
tweeting and all that every time a new
little gadget came out you double jumps
you had this guide you have that and
we'll go through those today hopefully
we'll get to see those and talk about
them as the link so Meghan Oz man yeah
thank you for that
you said trailer but that was Xbox one I
mean that was our level at the opening
of the game so it's pretty special to us
to show that yesterday open the show and
I remember that skyline just filled like
all these buildings with neon and like
the detailed it's not just the one
that's in front of you yeah it's babe
yeah that's what the next-gen can bring
you that's what three years of
development can bring of it just all
that detail and all that research that
we put into it all right well let's get
into it here we're gonna take a look at
the footage we saw yesterday starting
off in Seoul South Korea yep and this
the situation does not go well for these
guys in the drop pod you're dropping
about 70,000 feet into Salt is about
10,000 guys dropping into salt now we
just go a little off course this is the
introduction of being the advanced
soldier right a Tier one operator of the
future and everything it brings
showcased by the XO and just what that
means to you as a player and how it
changes call of duty you know but some
things about combat when you get more
advanced tech they change drastically
but other things like stuff going wrong
battle yeah ever changes that's right
you know even we're talking with our
Tier one guys who are consultants
they'll tell us things go wrong you know
they said we asked him I remember we
were asking our seal and he said yeah
you guys don't show things going wrong
enough because that's what happens on
the battlefield so clearly things
they're going also we start off with
showing something wrong and so we start
off and we get our early look at the
exosuit and that's the thing that lets
you do a long jump do it hard melee
attack to that double jump and so it's a
game changer man and that's what I'm
gonna you know I'm getting at is so many
things across the Call of Duty series
have been changes to weapons changes to
setting but this seems like the first
time it's really been a change to player
capability to player movements and I
mean that just opens up a whole new
world for you guys in terms of level
design and stuff like that it really
does you know coming out of modern
warfare 3 you know we had a great time
working on that game but we heard loud
and clear that we needed to innovate and
so you know the XO and the advanced
soldier really came to life right after
we got done with him interview 3 and the
boost jump which is one of our first
prototypes with the XO almost three
years ago before you know the XO became
pop culture through Elysium and you know
it was sort of a game changer as Glenn
describes it it gives you strength and
speed and and just it opened up a whole
new world for us and so you know a lot
of the variety for out call Duty
campaigns passed has sort of been level
by level you're in this specific
scenario it's gonna play out with these
sort of parameters but this is the kind
of thing that you know you could
conceivably have through most of the
game and that that really makes you guys
rethink I guess what kind of combat
situations you're putting the player in
yeah I mean there's a lot of riot in
this game as well but yeah the
exoskeleton opens up a whole bunch of
stuff we're talking about the grappling
hook and cloak but we also have an
upgrading system so at the end of each
level you've earned some points to put
into your XO and
you know kind of designed it the way you
want to play it so you customize you can
I mean are you talking about
you know leaning into a more mobile
class or a more powerful class or
depends if you want to have faster
reload you want to be a little faster
you want to be stronger those sorts of
things
I mean this is this is now you're on the
ground floor you know you you've entered
really the battle between North Korea
and South Korea right Call of Duty's
about RIT from the headlines you see
stuff there huh and you know North Korea
and all the tension with South Korea has
finally sort of kicked off this epic
battle said you know 40 years in the
future and one of the first thing I
noticed actually did you see playing out
right on the gun here is this is that 3d
printing bullet you guys are teasing
before Yeah right I had read about it
into it then all of a sudden I see that
little the gut the bullet filling up in
that number ticking right right it's one
of the many cool little tech touches you
guys packed in I've even added a brand
new class of weapons called the
directed-energy weapon which you'll see
later Call of Duty is about you know
being relatable and grounded and so
everything you're gonna see is grounded
in the research that we know is
happening today so the 3d printed weapon
that I'm are here the walking tank
I mean directed-energy weapon the smart
grenades this is not science fiction
this is Call of Duty this is stuff that
we know is in development today will be
on the battlefield tomorrow you can
watch youtube videos of this stuff being
prototype yeah I mean and you know it's
it's been a lot of research with the
three years and no science fiction again
fact there was a article on Yahoo a
couple weeks ago about you know the
introduction of the first EXO to the
army like that basically announced Iron
Man is here right really prototype now
in the battlefield in two years so this
what you see here is what the future of
battle looks like and it's terrifying
yeah I gotta say possibly the most
unexpected thing it's just a swarm of
drones right but they're they have that
kind of flocking vent out like exactly
algorithm or whatever is in there but
here we are
new feature as well you can go up and
grab an open door because you got that
strength that comes with the exoskeleton
it they're gonna bash it a little bit
but at least you're protected this next
section is uh pretty exciting too it'll
show you a whole bunch of what's gonna
start off with one of our brand new
grenade types it's called
threat detection and it really helps you
identify to come back on the field so
your variable can aid you move it our
threat detection sends an our feedback
to your augmented reality and there you
go you know what's going on and then
boom and then a little bit later we see
sort of like Scott toss it up in the air
and the great figures out there that
seems like a good plan right
got the new shotgun and we're gonna go
behind a mobile turret yeah what is this
firing cuz it looks it looks like
there's almost a sort of sonic the
repercussions or percussions coming out
of it yeah that was what our new shotgun
types and here we go oh yeah this is it
and we're behind a mobile turn right now
you might notice as soon as you go into
ATS the window pops down
oh I notice no it's one of these watch
and you're just like oh wait at every
corner right new at every corner yeah a
lot of detail man you know alright this
is a mobile platform that what they do
is they flying really quick they level a
whole bunch of people and then they take
off so we found one and we've got to
take it out before it goes okay so when
it is this one right here well it's
almost like a scud missile the future
you know they would spy a Scud and then
they would go hide uh-huh and this can
take off really quick we found one and
we got to take it out okay cuz you know
that's what's causing serious problems
for you guys drop it in there you go
heavily armored so you have to you found
an access panel and you're gonna
sabotage it essentially and again
something goes wrong yeah and of course
call duty the series no stranger to
dramatic moments for soldiers but tragic
moments for soldiers what is the you
know what can you give us an idea of
sort of the personality of these the
soldiers you are you know you guys are
writing into this game yeah well that's
one of the things that we did spend a
lot of time on as well
has been the story and we we try and
have compelling you know rich characters
because we want people to engage in it
and and that's one of the things we're
doing here we're trying to show the
camaraderie now in this case wait for
this moment a bit but yeah yeah this is
private Mitchell this is the guy that
you're gonna be taking through the whole
game
we don't switch from character to
character so here he's got a little
flesh wound yeah it was a little
surprising when you know it gets even
but we can notice even on his face we
can start to show the emotion when he
realizes what has happened right he's
like oh yeah all right we're gonna get
you a robo arm or something something
future techy no doubt maybe just one arm
or maybe just one arm in it we love the
you know the power of emotions in our
next generation sort of facial capture
that because almost everything I do I do
it's true choked up well you've got you
know Glenn here that he's with you he's
your rock I'm the rock yeah alright
we do have a couple questions coming in
over Twitter of course George McNeill
wondering about split screen multiplayer
on Xbox one and you know folks this is
the way these things go if you saw a
single player at the press conference
that's probably what we're talking about
today is that right guys yeah I'll let
him answer that one well yeah what do
you got well we are gonna have
multiplayer sure shocking but we can't
really talk about it but what we can't
tell you is everything you saw in that
demo everything that you've seen in the
trailers the possibilities of advanced
tier 1 technology brought to multiplayer
and co-op let your imagination run wild
and what's that I hear yes that's the
sound of thousands of imaginations
running wild and groaning at that silly
joke that I just let so you guys you
know they we got a little more time here
so let's talk about campaign a little
bit more that was that setting as north
or no the north south korea conflict is
that is that sort of the major focal
point that battle that that
or or is it you know Call of Duty tends
to tends to take things a little bit
more global yeah I mean that's a bit of
a head-fake but what we really wanted to
do in this game when we set up the story
was to show the rise of the PMC or the
private military corporation because
that's sort of ripped from the headlines
a corporate military growing and that's
where we have a lot of focus that's
where we got Kevin Spacey as the head of
the PMC's yeah of course and he's
conspicuously absent from this year I
guess yeah guess but I wanted to show
some action right you know I just threw
that in there yeah yeah Spacey that's
all you do now it's right if you go
anywhere you go you just drop do the
Kevin Spacey game just calm keV and look
to be honest though Kevin Spacey's
involvement it's not a PR stunt it's not
a headline grabber it's about bringing
impactful performance and really rich
narrative and and he is awesome yeah
well then we wrote the story you always
have the characters in mind for the and
and he was the guy that we had in mind
for irons and to be able to go out and
get him really shows the power of call
of duty but certainly has he added so
much and that's the thing you guys were
sort of mentioning you know that realism
of facial capture technology are we at
the point where the tech is so good the
tech is just so good it is it it almost
becomes you know it becomes more about
the performance of the actor so the tech
is sort of reached the point where it is
a little bit more invisible and that the
actor is more important the facial stuff
now is so important when we're doing the
capture absolutely yeah I mean look
Kevin gets in fully suited up and he
gets in there and he delivers
world-class performance it's like we're
used to out of them and it elevates
everybody around him and so now you're
absolutely right it's not the technology
although the technology is incredible
and to beat on the avatar to stage where
Cameron's filming and then we're filming
is awesome and to now tell us all
secrets about avatar
I'll tell you that cars multiplayer a
minute but but it's really about the
performance of the actors and really who
better today than Kevin to bring
Jonathan irons to life yeah yeah you
ready to eat you up
very nice Michael glad shirt thank you
guys so much for coming on talking some
advanced warfare having a great showing
at e3 so far and may it continue a
fare-thee-well thank you so much tell
the fans oh actually we didn't talk
about a release date yet did we you guys
are but free November 4th right of
course
we order now at any time before November
4th army gifts gifts you shower them yes
so generous of you gentlemen all right
thank you again folks we're gonna be
back live on this stage with another
Titan of the FPS genre halo but first
we're gonna take a look at some of the
highlights from Nintendo directs their
press conference this morning it's a
Mario maker visit to build your own
Mario levels and something else which I
totally forgot and you're gonna find out
about right now